it's almost holiday time and the team at  EADS software just gave doom fans an  early present I'm Tony and this is your  demon infested GameSpot news update  dooms blood fall expansion is available  right now on Xbox one ps4 and PC ahead  of schedule this DLC adds three  multiplayer maps new hack modules a  Spectre pinky demon and new armor it  also adds a new grenade launcher that  can bank shots off of walls or fire a  smoke grenade as a secondary option  blood fall is included in tombs $40  season pass but you can also grab it by  itself for 15 bucks doom made GameSpot's  list of the top 5 PC games of 2016 you  can check out the rest of our picks  right now and tune into our game of the  year livestream on Tuesday December 20th  at 10 a.m. Pacific we'll have all sorts  of special guests and prizes for you  there for all the latest from its  software and doom you're already in the  right place